all right good afternoon members
officers and members of the public who
may be watching this on the authorities
YouTube channel and to welcome to the
Planning Committee meeting of the first
of July as usual I will run through see
who is with us this afternoon with
members and officers I am aware that
there are some apologies so I won't call
those names out so if you can sir yeah
and they pleat what if you say if I
don't hear you I know you're not there
obviously a councillor curry here chair
Thank You counselor counselor as Eskie
present chair council of a foot present
chair councillor Coleman cook president
chair comes to the heart
I know councillor hearts there somewhere
have we lost him I know I am we know
he's here with us council right here
caster Ghana
I'm here to counsel Scott here chair
councillor keen here chair and
councillor Pat Moore I'm here chair
thank you I'm here obviously mouth chief
leader officer Estelle is still with us
Thank You Estelle
Emily Kennedy our committee Clark in
Livingstone and even Applications
Manager Emma somewhere thank you
I believe he is only yourself Emma this
afternoon well if I'm wrong speaking
thank you I'm back I'm afraid right
thank you
no I just did call your name out cancel
heart but I have ticked you obviously as
here so as usual a few notes to read to
you and if you have any technical tip
teased during this meeting please
contact Democratic Services on call who
will attempt to assist you today's
officer is Charlotte and her number is
five double seven 193 her number will be
including at the top of the chat stream
box for you to see and for your
convenience I would ask participants
when you are not speaking please mute
your microphone this minimizes
background noise and will help everyone
in listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak to gain permission please very
briefly indicating the chat box on the
right hand side of the screen and I will
make a note and come back to you when
your turn has come but everybody present
please make sure that their mobile
phones are turned to silent and they are
not used to make or receive phone calls
while this meeting is in progress please
also refrain from checking emails on
conducting other business and ensure
that you are in a quiet room free from
any disturbances distractions and that's
throughout the meeting please note that
this meeting is being live-streamed for
members of the public and following the
meeting the recording will be available
on the council's YouTube channel members
requesting to speak under casino council
procedure 20.1 request to speak have
been received from a counselor pew on
agenda items 3c and 3d is there now the
member who is watching us or joined us
who wishes to speak on any item
No okay thank you very much very
Japanese speaking sorry Chad I think
crisp you can make the cold I think he's
been tied up at work
sorry I don't speak and make his um chat
because he's been tied up at will be
tied up on a meeting I believe okay but
when it comes that we're you know we're
deal with that Thank You councillor Hart
public speaking that the following
applications have been reserved for
public speaking with members please note
the following items on their agenda
agenda item 3b a Oh to agenda item three
cro3 and agenda item three d d o4 moving
on to agenda item one apologies from
absence I have apologies from
councillors urban Duckworth and Taylor
to whom once again council recess key
he's standing in for it's good
councillor Dennis I believe I'm correct
is there any other apologies it's
actually kind of chefs key is actually
today Dennis see I beg the pardon was a
second ago he was and he's still trying
to get back in but I'm on call with them
to try make sure that he stays in he'll
be back okay right so look welcome to
council attendees to do being a pardon
on that one because I know councillors s
key has sat in in previous meetings
gender item - are there any decorations
of interests no thank you
agenda item three the schedule of
planning applications and public site
public speaking once again
if any site visits are required this can
only be done when it will be safe for
all of us to attend a site agenda item
3b the planning application for approval
AO 259 Norfolk Road Margate I would ask
our chief Atlee law officer Estella to
read out a statement was in favor of
this application from mr. Braun
Estelle nature this proposal was part of
a comprehensive scheme for the mixed use
of an existing large building in Norfolk
Road in the heart of Cliftonville
permission has already been granted for
the community use of the ground-floor
before this use can be implemented it is
important to secure permission for the
use of the upper floors that previously
form parts of a residential training
center the upper floors can easily be
converted to large and spacious
apartments that significantly exceed the
national standards for residential
accommodation and provide good quality
living for couples and small families
without compromising the amenities of
adjacent residence a previous previous
permission for redevelopment of the site
permitted 12 dwellings including five
apartments the scheme is not that
different in its residential composition
the residential conversion of the upper
floors will make a useful addition to
the present shortfall in housing
provision in the district the existing
design of the building does not enable
individual gardens to be provided
instead a communal garden area is
provided to the rear of the building by
demolishing an existing large
single-story extension the conversion of
the building to apartments is the most
sensible way of reusing the existing
structure and ensuring that the ground
floor can be retained for community use
the retention of the building is a more
sustainable option than its demolition
and the removal of the ground floor rear
extension an external fire escape
reduces the density of development on
the site and improve
is its appearance in the conservation
area the external alterations required
have been kept to a minimum
following helpful discussion with the
planning officer the applicants are
happy to work further with officers in
terms of window designs to ensure the
development compromises an improvement
sorry comprises and improvements of the
conservation area the ground front
extension has been retained through the
previous grants of permission for the
ground floor as a conservation officer
considered it an important element that
showed the evolution of uses of the
building it is not part of this
application the officer report confirms
the applicants willingness to make
contributions to local immunity
requirements through a legal agreement
the development does not meet the
present threshold requirement for
affordable housing
the report also confirms that the
development proposed will not create
highway concerns because societies in
such a sustainable location and the
development proposed may well result in
a reduction in traffic compared to its
previous high-density uses the scheme
will bring back into use a large vacant
building it will provide additional
large residential units that maximize
the use of the building reduce its bulk
and improve its appearance the scheme is
part of a proposal that will provide
space for community facilities at the
ground floor it is trusted that members
will support the officer recommendation
to approve this beneficial proposal
Thank You Stella on behalf mr. Brown
Renault are you if you would to read the
report sorry the German public speaking
statement raising points of concern from
a mr. Ward Estelle Thank You chairman so
a statement for them from the residents
Norfolk road heading a vision for
cliftonville the following paragraph is
the opening statement from flipped
unveil development plan cliftonville
will become a clean safe amiable place
where families and individuals will want
to live and take pride in existing
buildings will be well maintained
enhancing the special architectural
quality and history
a core value of the area there will be a
demand for properties within the area
and new development will be well
designed with an attractive townscape
incorporating high quality hard and soft
landscaping and encouraging biodiversity
there will be a strong community spirit
and residents will have pride in the
area the community will be a mixed and
settled one including families with
children living in accommodation suited
to their needs a range of household
sizes including apartments and family
sized homes with gardens and high
quality public green spaces Cliftonville
will be home to a number of quality
hotels able to accommodate the tourism
generated by the regeneration of Margate
and changing holiday patterns next
heading 51 to 59 Norfolk Road these
properties were originally six high
quality Victorian terraced houses during
the tourist boom this was then converted
into a hotel
adding poor quality ugly extensions
which are out of keeping with the area
more recently and until 2017 the
building was used as the Institute of
sand and sounds a Center for training
and spiritual leadership since 2017 the
building has remained unoccupied Albert
albeit some Guardian accommodation has
been made available the area has
increasingly attracted people loitering
drinking and dealing drugs next heading
flats Clifton will West has the highest
percentage of flatted accommodation in
the Thanet district a large number of
small flats means there is plentiful
supply of cheap flatted accommodation
this then attracts transient people and
adds to the deprivation cycle which
fuels the importation of socially and
economically dependent people as a
community we must re-establish a balance
where we can given that the
accommodation mix is currently heavily
skewed towards flatted accommodation it
is important the developments contribute
to changing this pattern this proposed
development is adding to the issues
faced by cliftonville West next heading
family housing
we believe the provision of high quality
family housing would help redress the
balance of accomodation mix and reduce
the current trend in seeking to make
Cliftonville across a prosperous and
attractive community again it is
important that attention is focused on
how developments in the area can
contribute to this and then in quotation
marks in new development or
redevelopment flats of any size will not
be permitted unless it can be clearly
demonstrated that there are overriding
design or townscape reasons for allowing
such development and that no acceptable
design solution can be found to
accommodate individual family dwellings
close quotation marks brackets from
Clifton mill development plan documents
close brackets there is clearly an
acceptable design solution to convert
these houses back to individual family
dwellings so much so that a planning
permission was granted in 2018 to a
change of use to five number four bed
houses one number three bed house and
five number to bed flats together with
erection of one number two beds Welling
three garages and alterations to the
fenestration this planning permission
was supported by the residents of
Norfolk Road next heading parking
parking is an issue throughout Clifton
will Clifton Hill West and Norfolk Road
is no different it is unrealistic and
disingenuous to say that the development
to a sixty bedroom hotel and is been
converted to 14 times two-bedroom flats
and therefore the stress on parking is
reduced the building has not been a
hotel for decades this development will
have a significant impact on the number
of vehicles coming into the area the
proposed development has no provision or
consideration for parking and the impact
this will have on the roads when the
property was a sixty bedroom Hotel car
usage was far less prominent than it is
today this must be taken into serious
consideration the cliftonville
development plan states with regards
parking quotation criteria to be
considered will include the length of
time
building may have been unused as hotel
accommodation the level and availability
of on-street parking within the
immediate vicinity of the site close
quotation blast head Inc residents of
Norfolk Road as residents of the street
we are putting our valued time and money
into our street to improve it a number
of properties have been converted back
into housing last year two properties
just doors up from 50 in family housing
and high quality of welcome this type of
development we have a strong
neighborhood community who take pride
and care for the street we get together
and litter pick every month and a wish
to see the street improve further if
this planning is allowed to go ahead the
building will remain in its current
state for decades to come
and the vision for Clifton bill will not
be realized in the way we all know it
can be as a residents of Norfolk Road we
do not support the proposed planning
application and respectfully ask that
this application is declined and it's
signed by 15 residents thank you Joe
thank Estelle speaking on the points
raised by mr. Ward and members and
officers I know our rules are three
minutes but I think we've touched on
this on these meetings before it is
quite difficult to rebut that in place
on these sort of kata your meetings were
having so it's interesting to listen to
that but I will see when we get back to
normal the three-minute rule will be
there but thank you Estelle I would ask
the officer please to outline the report
please Thank You chair um I'll just
share my screen
okay so the application is for the
change of use of the upper floors of of
the most 51 to 59 Norfolk Road
214 self-contained flats with the
erection of a first and second floor
extension to the rear alterations to the
fenestration as well as alterations to a
dormer window on the front elevation
fronting Norfolk Road and also with the
removal of a fire escape and rear
addition at the rear so the main issues
for members to consider for this
application are the principle of
development the impact on the couch and
appearance of the area and the impact on
living conditions of both future
residents but also the existing
residents surrounding site as well as
considering the impact on highway safety
and a few other material planning
considerations so the site is outlined
in red on the plan there it says on the
corner of where Cumberland Road meet
Norfolk Road
I've got some aerial images now so you
can see the location of the site and the
part of Clifton mill around it looking
then in a bit more detail as you can see
the extent of the site in a series of
buildings previously houses that have
been altered significantly over the
years and you can see that at the rear
there is a significant amount of built
form development that's come over the
years through the previous usage of the
site so then looking to show that on a
3d image so the site is in center of the
image here whether the mouse pointer is
and so you can see there are three rear
elements that come out from them out of
the building there and then this is a
view from the rear of the building so
you can see those four storey elements
those two four-story elements and the
three storey element that fronts
Cumberland Road as well as the large
expanse of
your story structure that's present at
the back of the property and then look
at the other angle you can see those
rear elements there and you can see
there are a number of windows in those
side side elevations okay so this is a
view from the corner so looking towards
the building so as mentioned in the
speech is previously the site is within
the cliftonville west renewal area which
is also part of the cliftonville
development plan document where those
particular policies apply it's also in
the conservation area which was
designated a few years ago and this is
an image just showing the main
elevations of of the the property so you
can see from look at this this this
image the number of the got two
different elements that have been added
to the building you've got a
single-story flat roof extension
fronting Norfolk Road as well as then
the three-story rear element here which
is much more modern addition to the
original building you can see from this
image that a lot of the windows have
been changed a points throughout the
years from timber windows to uPVC
windows before the conservation area was
designated in in 2017 so then the view
from Norfolk roads just got a few images
of this so you can see this the fire
roof extension at the front here and
then turning to the right you can see at
the top here you've got the double
window which is the subject of this
application to change that from a flat
roof to a pitched roof and then a viewed
back towards the building just showing
what it looks like at the moment and
then round on Cumberland Road this is
one of the other entrances to the
building and again you can see in a bit
more detail the the three-story more
modern addition then moving down
Cumberland Road and looking back tools
the building can see those four-story
parts the building of the back
and then there's the fire escape
here and then moving in a bit closer so
this fire escape is proposed to be
removed as part of the proposal and then
moving to look at where that fire escape
is you've also got a single storey
addition from here that actually
currently has a swimming pool that's to
be removed and demolished as part of
this proposal so there's demolition at
the back as well so going through the
plans of the proposal and the changes
that are being made on this front
elevations this is the Norfolk Road
elevation what members will see is this
is the the dormer window that we were
talking about so a pitched roof is
proposed on that on that dormer and then
on this elevation there is one one small
change to the window arrangement so you
can see there are lots of these sort of
modern smaller windows that have been
added in there at different times
it's proposed that some of these
openings are replaced by windows to
match the the star on proportionately
the windows that are present in the
building so you can see now there's a
pitched roof on top of this dormer and
it's bad and then there's a new window
in the center of the image on the first
floor then looking at the the very rear
elevation of the building with those two
full story elements so the proposal here
is to remove the fire escape and change
the the plan of fenestration here you
can see at the ground floor here there's
a slight change because the the the
ground floor covered swimming pool has
been removed and that's been demolished
and then at the rear here what you have
is some additional windows that have
been added in which would look out on
the floor plans we can't see from this
elevation but I will show you some
sections and second members is that
there is a first and second floor rear
extension in this area here which
doesn't protrude past the rear extent of
these two elements so it's within the
gap there
and then this is the existing side
elevation fronting Cumberland Road
looking at this you've got a new edition
of windows along the ground floor again
to match some of the style and
proportioning of the fenestration along
the bottom as well as windows that has
been added here to regularize
this appearance of the fenestration or
on that elevation and then just going
through the internal sections of the
building so this is one of the internal
sections of of the property so it's
looking actually sort of within where
those windows were on the 3d image and
just this is showing that there's a
slight change internally obviously the
rear extension has got on the bottom of
the image here with some of the windows
changing then looking at the section so
we've got what we're going to do is
gonna it's gonna have a little look at
this part of the building so on the
right of the image is Norfolk Road at
the bottom of the image is Cumberland
Road so we're sort of within the first
of the three rear elements so this is
currently what it looks like from
internally you can see the fire escape
on the right of the image there and then
you can see then the extent to which
there isn't a proposed first and second
floor extension so it's coming out from
the existing rear elevation but not
protruding past those rear elements that
are present at the moment and then
showing the other side that's same
element you can see then the rear
extension again some of the windows are
changing because of the extension that's
coming out but it's not protruding past
those rear elements at the moment and
then inside the other two rear elements
you have this window arrangement this is
being changed to include some Oriole
windows which will mean that Windows
serving the proposed frats will face
down the garden rather than face into
each other and we'll look at the floor
plans to see that and then this is the
other side of that rear element where
then you have a similar arrangement so
these are these built forms on
increasing size rather than having these
Oriole windows at
so this is the existing ground floor
layout so there is the previous use of
this property was as a hotel with 60
bedrooms up on the upper floors in 2019
so last year there was a painting use
application which was approved by the
council for a change of use of the
ground floor from AC to residential
institution use to a d1 which is a
non-residential institution use so it
was bit the property had been used for a
number of years as a training and
residential accommodation by the
Institute of santan Psalms for various
religious retreats and training sessions
and so forth and so that was Asti to use
and they use the building including the
upper floors and so the changing use was
granted to use the ground floor as a d1
use which could include number of uses
such as training a day center and those
uses and later on I'll show you the
approved floor plan showing those uses
well what you can see from this floor
plan is that the site is is almost in
time covered by built form at the moment
so what is being proposed is that the
rear the rear extension is being
demolished as mentioned there's been a
communal amenity space that's been
created at the rear from that demolition
with AB in storage and bike storage also
proposed there are two spaces for
visitor Park poems there is one secured
parking space that's actually to serve
the users on the ground floor as
previously approved but the main thing
to draw the members attention on this
layout are the entrance points for the
flats so you have two entrance points on
the ground floor fronting Cumberland
Road one is a new entrance that's been
created where the mouse cursor is here
and then another entrance
which is reusing the existing entrance
at the bottom of the image here and then
there's an additional entrance which is
again an existing entrance which is
through that single-story addition of
fronts Norfolk Road or on the right hand
side of the image here those give you
access to the upper floors so this is
the extent of the existing layout on the
upper floors you can see from this the
significant number of bedrooms and
ensuite toilets that are in this
premises a large amount of built formal
accommodation and so this is now being
changed on the first floor to have six
two bedroom units created the rear
extension is in this area here at first
and second floor and so what's what's
being proposed for access by the
staircases is one flat to the rear in
this area here another flat here then
you have another unit there another unit
at the back here so these are all access
file this staircase here these two units
here and then you have another flat
that's the front on corner and then the
last flat is accessed here which in that
corner you'll see from where the red
arrows are that the fenestration
arrangement has changed in these
internal elevations to avoid flats and
windows looking into each other so
that's why they've been orientated in
the way that they have such as as shown
and then on the second floor so we've
got pretty much an identical layout as
the floor below it first floor and the
proposal is then to mimic the layout of
the flats below so again six floors
sorry six flats being proposed there and
then moving on to the the existing third
floor so these are the two big rear
elements that you could see for all the
images what's being proposed is that
they would house two two units there and
then this is just a roof plan
again illustrates the look the extent of
the rear changes so just to show you the
ground floor layout as approved last
year before going through the issues so
you can see that this this shows an
indication of the particular uses that
have been approved so you have therapy
areas with insight as a training session
that is set so building then you've got
lecture space and communal training so
it has got a number of d1 uses that have
been approved within there so that in
terms of the principle issues that have
been raised in the report mentions been
they've been given to the cliftonville
and planned document and particularly
with regards to cv 3 which is the policy
for the provision of a family house in
new developments so that that policy is
specifically looking to ensure that for
redevelopments of sites and a new
development so and when you know we're
building new buildings and it's to
ensure that the basically flats are not
provided unless there are overriding
devine and Tans code reasons for
allowing such development and there's no
acceptable design solution can be found
now the preamble for that policy
specifically States and I'll just read
it out for members it states that the
provision of high-quality family housing
would help redress the balance of
accommodation mix and reduce the current
transient trend of residents that
develops from a high number of class
they will still be many properties
brought forward for conversion rather
than redevelopment so the policy is not
saying you can't wreak
you can't convert buildings into flats
it's specifically looking primarily at
built development however the council
and generally has looked at this policy
to ensure where we can buildings are
converted into dwellings as much as we
can we can get that to happen in this
instance the site has a significant
amount of built form on it you know over
60 bedrooms upstairs it's got very
significant depth of built form so even
with you know
area being demolished members could see
from those rear elements that there's
I've said four stories worth and
accommodation which doesn't mean who do
which doesn't make it possible to
convert the building in with the amount
of them that's on there at the moment
into dwellings very easily and so it's
is considered that the the development
has put forward would be supportive of
the principles of the aims of the
cliftonville DPD and specifically when
looking at policies h10 of the current
local plan which is looking at Clifton
and supporting a residential
redevelopment as well as the new draft
policy which is h8 which is talk about
the quality of the residential
accommodation created in this instance
all of the flats that are proposed are
above the nationally described space
standards so we haven't applied the
conversion flat guidelines from the late
80s on these we've applied the
nationally described space standards and
these flats do exceed those those limits
in terms of the impact on the character
in appearance the area previously the
scheme when it was submitted included
Juliet balconies included another
extension those have all been removed
and now as you've seen the changes are
mainly to regularize the feminist racial
arrangements with your minor window
changes in a picture of dormer the rear
extensions aren't visible because of the
way that they are not pursuing past the
existing rear elements and the removal
of the fire escape and the removal of
the single-story extension is is
supported and and is beneficial to the
conservation area so overall we don't
consider that there is a negative impact
on the conservation area from the
proposed as mentioned in terms of living
conditions of future occupants that all
of the flats are are you know
significant in size and would create
quality accommodation obviously they've
provided outdoor amenity space which has
been accommodated by demolishing the
structures that are there and also we
have looked at whether or not the
development is actually compatible with
what's been approved on the ground floor
and that approval on the ground floor
included
a number of conditions to do with
opening hours and also to do with sound
insulation so we do consider that future
residents won't be affected by the
operations at ground floor in terms of
impact on neighbors are all third-floor
windows that serve bathrooms that are
suicide facing will be obscured glazed
and all of the other windows are not
been a significant increase the amount
of overlooking that that currently
exists and the other big issue to touch
on is impact on highway safety sonam of
concerns been raised about the highway
impacts of this as has been outlined in
the officer report the previous use of
the building as a hotel was he created a
certain amount of vehicle movements but
primarily the most recent news and the
lawful use of the building is as a
residential Institute a/c to use and
that does create a significant number of
movements that come with that use and
therefore significant weight is put on
that when considering what the impacts
of this proposal would be and KCC
highways have raised no objection on the
basis of the 14 units that are being put
in comparison to the residential
institution operating on this site with
the number of bedrooms and facilities
and type of parking would be created
from a training center would he provide
it's also a very very sustainable site
by virtue of its close proximity to
amenities on cliftonville High Street as
well as close proximity to the bus
routes so it's not considered by
officers that there would that there
would be a ground for refusal that would
that would stand up and appeal on the
basis of that comparison between the
extent lawful use of the premises
contributions are being provided towards
the special protection area because it's
new residential accommodation as well as
towards education facilities in the area
and that's that's all outlined in the
our officer report a unilateral
undertaking has been submitted which is
been checked by officers and so
therefore this application is is put
forward for approval as it's considered
that it accords with both the new draft
local plan the previous local plan as
well as the Cliftonville DPD and
therefore the
nation is is for approval thank you
Nicomachean I move that the officers
recommendation is adopted could I have a
seconder please seconded sure Thank You
members do you wish to debate this
application quick comment on this when
you look at the front of that building
it has not absolutely awful sort of
1970s 80s
red brick frontage doesn't it that goes
onto the road absolutely great as the
rest of the street is that going to
remain well can that be taken away yeah
it's it's proposed to be retained as
part of this part of that has come from
so that the ground floor isn't actually
some part of the proposals for this
application but the previous application
from 2019 is looking to reuse the spaces
that have been created to use it for the
the day center that they're proposing to
use so no it's not proposed to remove
those elements Thank You councillor Kean
okay thank you yeah I've got a number of
concerns about this in particular the
cliftonville West is a really high
density area and we've worked really
hard to try and address some of the
problems that that causes and that's why
I think it's so important that the
principles within the Clifton deal
development plan of creating family
homes and limiting the number of flats
should stand fast in this instance and I
think that summit I mean although it's
been said that the apartments are
spacious I don't think 14 flats within
that is actually spacious accommodation
and there seems very limited communal
space for 14 flats worth of people by
the looks of the diagrams we've seen I'd
also like to comment on the parking
and it is already a very problematic
area for parking around there and to
build 14 flats with only two visitor
parking spaces is going to create more
traffic
I appreciate what's being said about its
uses the hotel and a training center but
actually it hasn't been used as anything
for a few years and in that time more
flats have already been built in the
area increasing the number of cars of
parking around there okay thank you
councillor curry Thank You chair yeah
yeah I do have some concerns about this
application I do recall an application
was passed to change from the hotel to
five four-bed houses one three baits
have been flats a while ago don't know
what happened to that application now we
have this one that's come in I do worry
if this application was passed how this
development would evolve over time
no private Gardens fairly compacted
apartments and sort of vague plan for
the ground floor I do have real concerns
how this type of development would
evolve who would want to live there and
how they would live there and so yeah
how I heard do happen some issues there
Thank You chair Thank You councillor
garner thank you yeah I've just wanted
to ask a quick question about the
comment from TDC Harrison in the report
and that ask for affordable housing to
be yeah on this site and I don't think
there is any can you just explain what
the reasons are for that please yeah can
you so so the application is for is for
14 residential units the the current
threshold in the current local plan
is for is that on demand sites where 15
or more units is proposed then we would
look to seek 30% on site affordable
housing so the report talks about this
briefly that obviously this is the the
current threshold for affordable housing
it is worth taking the opportunity to
know that for any application that comes
in how about this if next week the local
plan is adopted then for any application
that's received by the department after
that date for ten or more units then we
would be able to seek affordable housing
at a rate of 30% on sites there is a
change in the threshold that's going to
occur but for this application which has
actually been in for quite a while as we
try to resolve it it's not there's no
requirement for affordable housing on
this site under policy thank you Thank
You councillor comment cook yes thank
you chair my concerns the obviously
really that this there was permission
for four houses not viable financially
especially at the moment financially
that's not viable
so what worries me is that if this
application is not proved then the
people of Norfolk roads are going to get
a crumbling wreck slowly and worse in
their neighborhood because nobody is
going to take this on board each one of
those houses would have to cost about a
million pound to make it viable so
that's what worries me
thank you Jeff Thank You councillor I
cannot see anybody else wishing to speak
here so I'm going to put this to
yourselves and again I will call out
your name and if you could answer by for
the motion for against or abstain I
would be grateful
councillor Coleman cook war counseling
job hayford for council Aaron curry
against counselor John Dennis is he with
us no okay all right don't worry castle
my Karma
against councillor David Hart against
councillor Heather Keene against the Pat
Moore against counselor Walter set key
or council Matthew Scott against council
and in the write myself I'm for it and
everything tell you me I see councillor
Bay feds name come on here I'm sorry
counts the bay fir die yeah it's okay
I'm voted for it anyway right thank you
the motion is lost so mr. Livingston so
um the the issue with obviously the
motion being lost is then is then to
come up with an alternative motion given
the fact that members of express
concerns those those members that spoke
in the debate if expressed concerns
about the density of vermin in that area
and specifically the conversion to flats
with some worries about impact on
highways on the area the issue that's
created by this in officer view is that
on the highway side of things
it is very clear that there is a lawful
use of the premises which generates a
certain level of movements as well as
the fact that the site is in a very
sustainable location and members have
not not obviously not this planning
committee but in previous past we have
had an appeal in Windham Avenue which
the other end of Clifton militant extent
which looked at this particular issue in
an HMO was refused appeal and in that
instance if we were the appeal was lost
and costs awarded on the basis that we
members couldn't substantiate all the
council can substantiate a reason for
refusal on the basis that it was in a
sustainable location so in my view I
don't think that is a sustainable reason
for a fuse on to put forward on our
highways grounds um given given the fact
of what's been outlined about
specifically about the Clifton of the
DPD and particularly with regards to the
fact that this property is you know it's
a large property that's being put
forward for conversion and no members
mentioned that there is I've seen the
previous application that's been
approved on the side I think it would be
prudent in this instance that officers
take away members concerns about this
application rather than formulate a
reason for refusal now that the item is
there for deferred back to officers to
provide into potential reasons for
refusal along the lines of being
contrary to Steve III and potentially
providing additional information about
why the application in officer's view
couldn't necessarily be provided with
the item then being reported back to
members a following Planning Committee
to allow for members then to make the
final decision with with that
information provided to them to decide
whether or not to refuse it on the basis
of that policy or not that that's my
recommendation to members and if members
have an alternative motion then then
that can be put forward
either as that all or something else
thank you in as chair I think what mr.
Levinson know dead a fair comment to
come back to us
I would like a proposer if that is if
you fall that is agreed and a seconder
please i'ma go to vote on that
Oh chair please your proposed L sarcoma
cooker second to please Thank You
members I won't go through all the names
again I think that is very fair that it
does come back to committee with some
answers which you generally think that's
okay can i yeah yeah yes agreed yeah
yeah yeah thank you I think in fairness
they've been it through all the names
again is Helms that's positive and
that's carried so thank you in look
forward to a report when it comes around
Thank You members for that
moving on to agenda item three see the
patient or a funeral land northwest of
Dumbarton Road Burton back to Estelle
now who will read out a public statement
in favor of the application from mr.
brown Estelle yes thank you chairman
Senate had causing shorted while the new
local plan provides new sites the
planning inspector have made it clear
that more sites are needed once the
local plan must be reviewed straight
away
Kovach 19 has caused larger builders to
stop building and will lead to delay
delays in supply smaller sites that can
come all quickly will help combat the
shortfall this is one such site that
Nicholas village has been identified as
a village capable of accommodating
additional housing prior to the new
local plan several sites have been
granted permission the print
Cipolla edge of village development has
been accepted the main consideration in
determining these applications has been
to avoid impact upon long views into and
out of the village late last year
permission was granted for a bungalow at
huckleberry farm in down Barton Road
that site is next to this application
site in deciding to grant permission
councillors considered that the bungalow
was in a sustainable location because
the bungalow a single-story and the site
hunch is around it councillors felt it
would not have an impact on the views
from the village this bungalow has a
tree screen right behind it the building
will not go above the height of the tree
screen and will not have an impact upon
the long distant views while the
application is in that outline an
illustrative scheme has been submitted
showing her below can be designed to
look like a stable count of character in
the area the applicant is willing to
accept a condition requiring him to
build the bungalow to look like a stable
on the same agenda is a proposal for a
stable conversion to a house next to the
supplication site which the planning
officer supports considering the
allowance of new houses on the edge of
the village close to this site and the
need for new housing counselors are
asked to support this scheme if members
approve the application a draft legal
agreement has been submitted to agree to
pay the SAMS contribution for the
dwelling and that's the end thank you
chairman Thank You Stella once again I'm
going to ask you to read a statement
raising points of a concern from a mr.
assignment I believe that's how you
pronounce it Thank You chairman this is
a form of an email dear sir or madam I
would like to take this opportunity to
voice my opinion to the above planning
application as per the previous month
the same content and planning permission
are in motion again again this letter is
essentially still raising all the same
concerns as the previous seven
applications in the five months there
has been at least seven planning pingjun
submitted for areas
surrounding Dumbarton which community is
that every available piece of land is
looking to be filled with the property
despite having no issues with the
intentions of this planning permission
my concerns are with this planning
permission are that it is merely a
gateway for similar properties to be
built on the adjoining piece of the land
northwest of down Barton Road we can see
from the previous planning permissions
for the land northwest of Don Barton
roads brackets such as 2000 bleak Oh 4-5
117 oblique 4/5 before sorry I'll start
again 17 oblique 141 280 nobly Oh 567 20
oblique 0:06 219 oblique Oh 8 1 8 close
brackets that this is potentially the
end goal if the initial property is
granted permission via this planning
mission it is evident from the case
notes that previous planning permissions
and intentions are well highlighted the
infrastructure shortcomings highlighted
with the previous planning applications
are still present in down Barton Road
despite living in down Barton Road for a
little over 12 months these are still
apparently obvious kind regards craig
scime and Cassie Smith thank you
chairman Thank You Stella I think we
lost a few I don't know about other
members and officers have lost a few
words there but the content I think is
clear and that understandable if members
agree thank you
I'm not sure whether councillor Pugh has
arrived at all for his comments no it
doesn't look like it so I will go over
to the planning officer for her report
please
okay so the application site is outlined
in red on the screen p-please can you
see the presentation
yes that's fine okay great so we've got
down Barton Road is the main road
running through the center of the screen
you can see the application site
outlined in red and the left of this
site is huckleberry farm which was
considered a committee if you want to go
by members for the election between
within that site and just the context
just to the right hand side of this
outlined in a darker gray line is
another application that's on the agenda
today for consideration so this is a
will be showing the sites you can see in
the bottom left-hand screen where the
red dots is that's the application site
so it turns out the context of the
village it's quite far from the main
center of the village to the main center
running through and the length of the
high street or the middle of the site
here and then this is just an aerial
view of the application site so the
application site is this piece of land
here so it's currently paddocks use with
the grazing of horses it's not the
entire part of this site but just the
left-hand side of this site and then
this is just a view again showing it so
you can see in terms of the surrounding
area there's a large area countryside
open fields opposite the site and behind
the site so the application site is is
again here
so this is now looking into the site so
this is towards the left-hand boundary
of the site so the left-hand boundaries
following this tree screen on the left
here so you can see the current use of
the site for four paddocks use and then
again looking into the site you can see
that there are whilst has some hedge
screening and on the rear boundary you
can see beyond to the open countryside
beyond and then this is again something
down bottom road with the application
site on the right-hand side so this area
here is the left and left side boundary
of the site where you can see there's
some existing tree screening but
otherwise the this site is very open and
then this is further back along down
Barton Road looking towards the
application site so the application site
is is the far end of this so there would
be the boundary of it once we go through
the middle of this site so in that in
addition you could see this is
huckleberry farm so this was the site
that was considered by members
previously remember to consider the
impact was acceptable because of this
tree screen and the dual reading that
was approved was to be erected behind
this tree screen so it was quite well
hidden from from the road
whereas in comparison you can see this
site is very open and then again just a
further shot looking towards the
application site again showing how open
it is and then this is looking but the
other direction with down Barton Road on
the right again you've seen far the far
right-hand boundary is again a hedge
screen but the actual boundary of this
application site runs through the center
of this area and then this is just
looking at the left and Leslie boundary
so again looking now towards huckleberry
farm just you can see this was the
access and you see the screening around
huckleberry farm and again looking
towards the front of huckleberry farm
again you can see what screen
existed around the site and again
looking into it you can see there was
already some built fall within the site
whereas this site is is it completely
open so the proposal was in outline form
for the erection of a single dwelling
and all matters are reserved but this
is an indicative plan suggesting how the
layout of the site would work it shown a
single unit towards a sensor which would
appear to be with a dual pitch roof
quite a deep unit with a single access
on the down bar some Road and it's also
showing the potential for some tree
swinging ahead screen and around around
the site this is an indicative plan of
how it could look so it's suggested that
it could be single-story in scale and
have to stay but appearance but again as
you saw previously you would it would be
quite deep unit again the indicative
floor plan of how this unit would look
so the main issues is that the site is
located outside of the village it's
within the countryside and it's within
the last eight character area an
application for this identical propose
was previously refused and by the
council in March of this year
this application is coming again given
the decision that was made though
although have the huckleberry farm
decision was actually made prior to this
previous refusal in terms of considering
the need the draft local plan now has
significant weight where it were very
close to its adoption so we don't
consider that there's actually a need
for this units and your single units are
providing very minor economic and social
benefits through its provision in terms
of this area there's been significant
applications have come forward in in
previous years for conversions of
buildings and erection of new buildings
and many of those have been to appeal
and in in all cases the inspector has
considered that the impact on the mascot
character area is very significant in
this in this area the Nazca character
area the characteristics of it in this
location is is that it is open
undeveloped which contributes to the
rural character of the area and also the
long distance panoramic views that are
provided by by sites within the area so
in this particular site given the fact
it's surrounded by open countryside the
erection of a new dwelling in this area
would result in significant harm to the
landscape character area while some
screening is suggested with India
and suggesting that you could have some
landscaping along the boundaries of the
soil to hide it that in itself is is not
adequate because it would actually white
erecting new landscaping it would
actually be contrary to the last get
carrot every which is supposed to be an
open site so there would be concerns
concerns with that so whilst the site I
mean you can see from the road there's
no flipped off links through the village
and this has proved to be raises
concerns with with previous applications
the fact that it's quite poor links to
the village without that foot of
connection but again with the with the
approval that members gave to the
Drennen at huckleberry farm it's
considered that curry would be
unreasonable to person continue to
object to a development because of the
lack of proper vision given the fact
that this is closer to the village then
huckleberry farm site however the site
is considered to be under stain and
sustainable in the fact that it does
rosamma significant harm to the
environment and this is not outweighed
by the very minor benefits for just a
single thread in is therefore
recommended for refusal thank you
Thank You Kermit I move that the
officers recommendation is adopted could
I have a seconder please second de jure
up to there I'll let him Ellie if
recognize the voice pick pick who you
want right members I think so yeah yeah
Thank You councillor SSK members you
wish to debate this you've got all very
quiet on me I can't see anything on my
screen okay double check okay
there's no comment on my screen so I'm
going to put this straight to the vote
once again I think we all know how to do
it now but a four against and abstain
and I will call your names out
accordingly councillor Colin cook
against
counselor job hayford growing just to
clarify for the is to approve refusal
yes yeah for thank you very much
counselor Alan curry yeah for refusal
yeah for counselor John Dennis for for
Thank You councillor Dennis nice to hear
from you thank you
blank last time don't worry about it
I've had the same problems okay
counselor gamma abstain counselor dated
heart for refusal counselor head the
green Akeem sorry for refusal more
against Castle George's s key
yep for counselor Matthews Scots if you
sit with us for refusal counseling the
rights for a full refusal thank you and
I am for refusal as well it looks so
that is carried an office recommendation
just check with that is carried Thank
You members agenda item three D is the
planning application for deferral
stables land west of down Barton Road in
Burstyn once again I'm going to ask
Estelle to read out a statement from
again mr. Syme Estelle Thank You
chairman I hope you can all hear me a
bit more clearly this time so this again
is an email dis madam I would like to
take this opportunity to talk my opinion
to the above planning application as per
the previous month the same content and
planning permission are in motion again
again this les
is essentially still raising all the
same concerns as the previous seven
applications within the past 12 months
there has been at least seven planning
permission submitted for areas
surrounding down Barton Road as you are
aware there is currently a hundred and
twenty additional houses being built
within sint-niklaas
with the current trend identified by the
village community is that every
available piece of land is looking to be
filled with the property despite having
no issues with the planning permission
my concerns are with this Planning
Commission it is merely a gateway for
similar properties to be built on the
adjoining piece of the land northwest of
down Barton Road we can see from the
previous Planning Commission's for the
land northwest of down Barton Road
brackets such as 20 oblique Beaufort 6
617 oblique one-for-one 218 oblique oh
five six seven twenty oblique 0:06 219
oblique oh eight one eight close
brackets that this is potentially the
end goal if the initial property is
granted permission via this planning
permission the infrastructure sure the
infrastructure shortcomings highlighted
with the previous planning applications
are still present in down Barton Road
despite living in down Barton Road for a
little over 12 months these are still
apparently obvious kind regards craig
scime and Cassie Smith thank you
chairman thank you sterile
once again I don't believe councillor
Pugh is with us just checking
okay I let go to the plan officer to
give the report please I believe that
cemre
okay so and so the application site is
now outlined in red to the to the center
of this area fronting on to em down
bottom road you can see the outline of
the existing building within the site
and again an aerial photo showing the
location of the site so it's to the far
left of the screen here and then again a
photo again showing the site so it's
this area here you can see the existing
building and then another zoomed in
aerial view of it again the building is
here and then again just the right-hand
side here so you can see that whilst the
the site we've just just considered was
owned further over to the left and
surrounded by the countryside this is
slightly closer to the village you can
see in slightly closer proximity to
existing built development so this is
not fatal looking at the building itself
so it's a stable building that you see a
single-story timber Claire add red tiles
and you can see this fencing that runs
around the site so this forms the
boundary to the application site so this
area to the front here will remain open
and this fence line will form the
boundary of of the new dwelling and then
this again looking towards a site so you
can see the dwelling here and this fence
line running around and here and this
would then be the access into the site
on the left-hand side of the scrapping
and then again you can see the dwelling
on that other building on the left-hand
side and down Barton Road and again need
to see the proximity to existing
development and then this is looking
back the cross and the paddocks area
towards the same building and then this
is taken from the west looking towards
the site so the stable building is this
building here behind this hedge and then
further view again showing the views
from down barton road looking across the
site we've just considered and towards
the application site in the distance so
this application is a fed-up location
for the conversion of the sable building
into a dwelling so again you can see the
access running through the side of the
site here and then this area here would
to the right and left of it would form
the amenity space serving the dwelling
you can see the existing hedge running
it on the left and bound left-side
boundary and against the beer and then
it's proposed that there would be hedge
planting by that fencing I showed you in
the photo so to the right hand side and
to the front of the building where the
fencing is would would be head plans in
this is just showing the existing North
elevation and the post so it involves
the assertion of one Felix wind I within
the roof space and the two for the
insertion of two windows you see that
was the previous one and there's the
insertion of two windows within that
innovation so that's the majority the
main alterations that are taking place
so this is the front elevation and
that's now the proposed or such as using
the doors windows have been inserted
within the existing door spaces and
again slide elevation which remains the
same and then the other side of Asia
which also remains the same so the main
alterations were in the North elevation
and then these are the two wings these
are the internal elevations of the of
those wings projecting towards the front
of the building so there's company a
double door and a single door within
those two projections and they would
again be changed so that windows were
positioned within those openings so
there's very minor alterations taking
place to the building so this again
shows the existing layout of the
building and this is the proposed layout
so again there's no extensions or any
additions to building just some changes
to the fenestration
and then that's the existing roof level
that's the proposed roof level so
there's change here is just the addition
of this one V ducts window and in the
sections of the site so this application
this site has been considered previously
and it has been previously refused and
supported to appeal for refusal by the
inspector what has changed is that the
draft local plan now contains a policy
that supports develop in the countryside
where its previously developed land so
this site is considered to be preached
about land and therefore the principle
of the development in accordance with
the countryside policy of the draft
local plan is accepted so whilst the
site still is located outside of the
confines it would be supported by that
countryside policy so whilst we still
would have succeeded we have a five-year
housing supply now and therefore the the
overriding need for an additional single
wedding is very minor so there's very
minor social and economic benefits from
achieving that that has to be considered
to be against the environmental impact
in this case the building is is simply
remaining as it is with very very minor
alterations being the addition of just a
single V ducts window and some of the
doors turning into Windows so in terms
of the impacts of manasseh gate
character area the impact is very minor
the only additional impact would be
through the use of residential
paraphernalia around the building but
again to proposal to plant hedging along
boundary line where the fencing exists
would help to screen that low level
paraphernalia that will be provided and
therefore would again reduce any any
visual impact again previously the
impact stood in terms of the lack of
footpath links to the village was
considered by inspector and this was
considered to be unacceptable again
given the recent decision members have
made and for the erection of a dwelling
further out out from the British over to
the west again it was seem unreasonable
to continue to refuse the application on
the lack of a proper vision given the
fact that a drowning further out has
been approved about it so on this basis
it is considered that this scheme now is
acceptable subject to the provision of a
legal agreement securing the SPL
you should and therefore it's
recommended to be deferred and delegated
for approval subjects that need
agreement being submitted thank you
thank you very much
I move the officers recommendation is
adopted that is fir and delegate could I
have a seconder please second it two in
a row Council recessed key camps through
it I think yeah Thank You councillor is
estiven okay councillor heart you wish
to speak a chair I have slight
reservations about this the reason being
is obviously your thing going to take
away the main hours away from the main
field because obviously they are almost
linked per se also where the horse is
going to be stapled are actually in that
field if you get rid of their little
staple to make it into a house secondly
if there is where they actually
currently reside does that mean that if
the owner of that land then puts up
stabling block for the horses has had
been made homeless that can then be
converted at a later stage into more
housing and so therefore he's got his
planning through the back door if you
could just answer those questions for
very grateful thank you thinking of the
horses Emma I don't have any information
on where it's intended the horses would
would go I mean yes it's clear from the
photos there at the moment I would be
assuming that this space is no longer
required which is why the application
has been submitted to convert it in
terms of if they were to build something
else then there are some builders you
can build I'm the PD within agricultural
use but otherwise again they may well
consider planning to require a plan for
mission in which case we consider again
the impact of why and new stables would
be required when one previously has been
has been lost in that location
so yes I mean IQ I don't unfortunate
estate have information on what would
happen at this fair comment
cancerous eski hi yes
looking at your pictures there it seems
that it's going to be quite well
screened and it doesn't seem to be like
there's going to be too much adjustment
to the building just the odd bit of a
window here and there on a door it seems
to me but it seems quite a sensible
renovation I feel that I shall be
supporting this thank you
Thank You counselor counselor right
Thank You chairman I must admit I won't
be supporting this application I have
come across this one before four years
ago and I feel that this is a way of
Housing Development coming by self
stealth because there will be a stable
block comes along that will be turned
into a house and is but it was full
totally spawn the beautiful beauty of
the area thank you
Thank You counsel right castle Beauford
Thank You chair well I I can only only
considered the application we have
before us and as far as I can see there
is very little change it is unattractive
I'm not sure about the change of
residence from but I feel I have to
support this application as it stands
thank you thank you
I don't see anybody else at this stage
wishes to speak therefore I'm going to
put this to the vote and that is for
this our accommodation is to defer and
delegate gain members if you go through
this forest set for the motion against
or abstention capsicum and cook or try
and give it right this time chair thank
you we do understand and so Kate
councillor Beauford for councillor curry
for councillor Ghana for councillor
heart against councillor keen for
councillor Pat Moore for councillor
assess key for councils Ascot against
councillor Linda Wright against and
myself I'm for it I think that is
carried I always rely on Emily Dennis
we've forgot you for don't worry thank
you John thank you thank you for that
sorry about that
my list here thank you that is carried I
believe okay
confirmation I'm sure it is Thank You
Emily that it concludes public speaking
for this meeting I will call upon the
clerk to read out the remaining planning
application if a member wishes to
reserve an application
well they please call out as she reads
Emily does any member wish to speak okay
so can I have a pozer that the
applications that have not been reserved
be determined in accordance with the
officers recommendations could either
propose a please Emin sorry chairman
councillor Matthew Scott says he wants
to speak ah make a pardon I didn't see
that come up Thank You council Scott but
yeah hello I mean yeah just to get a bit
of an understand so I mean I trust them
are we having an EDD sort of the
presentation on this or sis
basically just going straight to vote on
those
though we're sort of on quite held for
time really so I mean that's my first
question to it no I mean apologize for
you I didn't see your rain come up on
the screen counts of Scots but I don't
think we've gone far enough
this can be debated I'm sure Henry will
correct me affirm if you wish it to be
it can be yes yes fine yes I thought so
okay
so could I ask three nor am I to give us
the presentation please of Suffolk
Avenue Suffolk Suffolk yes is that you
Emma
[Music]
all right so the application site is
this this area here so you can see the
existing buildings on the site so you
can see the shaded red area yellow and
blue area and these are the existing
buildings within the application site
Ithaca have you been on the right-hand
side and this is an aerial view of the
site you can see the application site is
towards this is the roof of the larger
manufacturing building then on the
right-hand side here is the office and
some more storage buildings and then
again the building off to the right here
is another plot site and she's also
storage you can see that access right
through the center of the site
connecting links field road to the top
of the screen it's a Suffolk Abril to
the bottom screen there's just another
view showing it so you can see the
existing buildings to the front here and
and then on the left you can see this is
all and your darío associated with the
site as well
then this is now so we can we have
Suffolk Avenue onto the right-hand side
looking with the buildings here and in
the distance here and there just another
view so this is not taken from the road
looking towards a site so just generally
looking at the character the area around
here you can see within Suffolk Avenue
and mainly semi-detached properties and
also there's a few terraced walls and
then road to the realism is mainly
Terrace units Avenue looking towards the
application site so the two white
buildings are the application site the
proposal is to demolish both of these
buildings this is the access running
through the center of the site so this
company isn't within the ownership of
the applicant which is the reason why
this application was removed from a
previous agenda it was so that this this
land could be advertised for any and any
potential owner to come forward but it
is unregistered land within the proposal
is intended that this would form the
access running through the site to the
units within the development this again
you can see the existing build in and
you can see there's a bungalow to the
right-hand side of the site before it
jumps up to main two-story houses in the
street and you see here the bomb grown
and the two-story houses and then this
is just showing the gap between that
building and the bungalow so you see the
gap that exists and the fact there are
some existing windows within that rear
elevation looking towards the
neighboring property and again you can
also see that the fence height exists
there and then this is looking towards
the large manufacturing building so from
towards the left the site so this has
been used previously for window
manufacturers but it's now back in in
use by the applicant wishes to do a
Furnham furniture manufacturing and unit
and again you can see the the yard area
on the left here and then this is
looking and towards not 24 static Avenue
in the boundary of the site there and is
where this wall is by the new wrong and
here
and then just showing you the name and
property to the left of site so there's
a I'm sorry there's a row of terraced
units or two-story in height and then
this is just shown the other side of the
road opposite the development this is
the start of properties and within the
streets are quite a simple two-story
picture of units then this is within the
site so this is now looking back towards
Suffolk Avenue with the manufacturing
build on the right and and the office
unit on the left and you can see the
large open and parking area that exists
within the site and to the right-hand
side here it's a two existing units
which fall outside the application site
which we'll see in a moment so this is
just looking at the storage building and
then this is down the side of that
storage building so this is between the
V renovate and rear boundary of the
properties in links field needs field
Road and then the existing site boundary
of the existing building you can see
there are a few trees down this access
point as well this this is quite a
growing here but I had previously been
to the site when this this wasn't this
overgrown and this actually forms a
pedestrian access route that connects on
to Livington Road and then just a view
again of that that same slide access and
then this is now looking to the
manufacturing building the right-hand
side here this is now the access that
links on to links field road and on the
left-hand side here are two existing
units out falling outside of the
application site this building here also
falls outside of the application site
this into dwellings within the sensor
there's access to the side of them that
runs to some garages to the rear and
again that is also outside of the
application site so the proposal is to
really develop the site to remove the
existing manufacturing and industrial
units and to redevelop for residential
use so the proposal is for a block of
and two-story terraced wagons to the
front here fronted on to Suffolk Avenue
and then a row of terraced one bed units
in this occasion here adjacent to number
12 and Suffolk Avenue the building to
the rear the manufacturing building
originally it was hoped that that Billy
could actually be converted because the
interest in roof shape of the building
but it was found not to be viable so the
proposal was now to demolish that
building but to an erect an identical
building with the same interest in roof
design and using the same footprint as
the existing building and this would
then provide for eight to bed Maison
it's within that space and then in
addition there's two to bed
semi-detached houses in this location
here so you can see they were using
utilizing the existing access so that
runs through the site there will be
parking located to the rear of the
terrace units although each of those
would also have a parking space at the
front of the site and this this row
three terraces here has a garden area
next to it plus and smaller guard areas
to the rear as well and you can see park
into the front of these eight units
along with vista parking spaces and each
of these will have their own private
community space that you'll see in a
moment with looking at the floor
patterns so this is this is the this is
a what was previously the manufacturing
building that's been demolished and
rebuilt identical to before to how it is
now so this is a fun innovation looking
into that open parking space and then
the rear renovation of it and then this
is a side so you can see the interest in
roof design that exists this is quite
useful and that allows those to be
inserted in the sides of the roof in
order to avoid overlooking of the
neighbors so you can see that while some
glazing these propose have been the
innovations of face of neighbors on here
you see the annotations showing that
those would be obscured based and fix up
whether that darker gray and this is a
ground floor plan so the proposal would
be that you would come in through a
single access point and then each of the
units would be accessed off this single
corridor that runs through the middle of
the building and then each Union would
happen zone courtyard area and then this
is first floor level of those units and
so again you can see now that the
internal and Harris areas that be wood
eighty-four each so this is avoiding
between two the territory above so it's
quite an interesting design and this is
so enjoying the sections or the units
and so that that was that block there so
we're now heading towards and the now
heading towards these units so numbers
nine to eleven so this is the side
elevation which is facing the internal
access road so again you can see it's
quite an interesting design with blaze
in its whilst it's suggested might be
three stories actually only two stories
has just got a high ceiling level within
the building these are one bit one bit
and terrace houses this is the rear
elevation which shows a very low east
level so again it's similar to the
existing loan that's on the site it's
bit further away from the boundary so
the interest in the name should be
reduced and it just shows there's no
first floor windows within this roof
space and this is the front elevation
and so this on the right hand side front
Suffolk Avenue and then the left hand
side is the rear and then this is just
showing the internal arrangement of
these units so now looking at the the
pair of semi-detached pair three terrace
units that towards the center of the
site so these these ones are they
catered in this area here so you see the
front innovation it's just over quite a
simple design gives the effect of a bay
bay window and then that's the rear
elevation
these are all solar panels within the
roof space missions and plans and then
looking at the front elevation of these
total units onto Safa caveny this is the
innovation V so it's because they're
just being keeping with the character
the road where there are there is
evidence of terrace units
many of the properties in the street
have big windows so the bay window
double bay we know effect of these units
was not a significant projection they do
have the effects of a bay design and
therefore obvious it's being keeping the
scale and you
of course in the street again this is
showing at roof level just the soda
panels into the unit and this is the
rear elevation and the side views of
those units and then the ground-floor
fan and the first one of the units are
they're all too big units as well so the
site is currently participate but it's
come the employment site through the at
the adopted plan or through the draft
accounts and allocated housing site for
a notional twenty three units which is
what the proposed was for for 23 units
so it is in accordance with the
principles in accordance with the draft
local plan in terms of the design asked
as pretty mentioned its is to be a world
well designed scheme that fits in with
the catch of the area you see it follows
the front and rear and Gildan eyes with
the properties and it's an interesting
design using sustainable materials so
the this is one of the key benefits of
the scheme is that the intention is that
it's a zero carbon with very sustainable
form materials use within the
development in order to make it zero
carbon and very sustainable so this is
support on a draft like a pan and the
MPP F which is pushing towards new
development that is zero carbon so this
is a very big benefit to the environment
through this through this scheme the in
terms of the impact on the neighbors you
can see there's an e in terms of the
block to the front there's only a small
gap between the units but there's no
side windows have been number 24 so the
impact on that property is considered
okay the in terms of looking at number
12 the the proposed development is much
further from the property than the
existing building and as you saw from
the design these level is still at
single-story levels it's not exceeded
there be any additional impact on light
or outlet from that property and there's
no first four window so the impact and
privacy is considered to be acceptable
within this rear block and all
first-floor windows as mentioned are
going to be a phase and fixed shut below
1.7 meters so the main issue that would
have been overlooking from these side
windows is addressed through through
that condition
and again this Terrace block in the
middle there's a distance of the access
road so again the impact on that
property would be acceptable highways a
very rate low concerns that the parking
is in the form of one space per unit
plus an additional seven seven visitor
parking spaces and highways are happy is
an existing access so the access onto
Suffolk avenues because it has to be a
safe access the only issue was through
the attorney for breakfast is expected
that you would have refuge vehicles
turning to the site and there is a
little bit of concern that there
wouldn't be space to do this without
double your lines either side of this
access so the proposal is is requiring
the applicants to try and work with KCC
in order to achieve WLAN lines either
side of the access to it to achieve
returning and for the refuge vehicle and
that would be secured within the legal
agreement that they would use best
endeavors in order to achieve those W
lines in terms of the contributions
offered that that the scheme doesn't
provide for any affordable housing or
any contributions towards infrastructure
viability assessment was submitted with
the application which has been
independently reviewed the the increased
build cost from the the zero-carbon
scheme has had some impact on the
viability at the same time it was
considered went by and what our
consultant that whilst build cost would
increase through the provision of this
zero carbon scheme the sales sales
prices would also increase so if you
were comparing this to a normal scheme
that was built with with standard
materials it would actually be very
similar because the the sales prices
that should be lowered with that scheme
so they're actually unique in either
case survivors here seems to be very
marginal and in which case it was agreed
that given the benefits of other
developments to the environment given
fact that ASA is it's very Martian and
we can't see that likely that we would
get any contributions from it that we
could consider the scheme without these
contributions and because the the
suggestion was that maybe we should have
a review mechanism within the agreement
basic city the scheme of this
of this small scow it's not considered
necessary to do so so the benefits are
that we're achieving and the development
of site for for housing for which we you
know we have a need because it's
allocated for that within the draft
local plan so we would receive
significant social and economic benefits
for the development site for the housing
there's environment significant
environmental benefits through the
zero-carbon skin it's being proposed and
the impacts on by fire raisin and the
neighboring properties is considered
acceptable so whilst there's some harm
lost from the loss of the affordable
housing and the financial contribution
it's considered on balance the benefits
of the scheme out outweigh the palm and
therefore it's recommended for approval
thank for that Emma I move the officers
recommendation which is for approval can
I have a second please also you know to
Thank You counsel common cook I have
three speakers at the moment for council
Byford Thank You chair yes it's a great
pity about the lack of affordable
housing apart from that I can't see
anything not to like it's a very well
planned sustainable development with
good variation
different types of housing I accept the
reasons for the lack of affordable
housing which I say it is a pity but
apart from that I can't see any reason
not to support this application thank
you
Thank You councillor Scott Thank You
chair yes a few questions in there
comments really I mean sort of I mean
first of all it's within my Ward's I had
disclosed from that I mean this
application been going on since I think
initially 2019 which is like the first
consultation about it I know that one
thing that was highlighted was the
concerns about from a southern water
about the drainage and sewage issues if
I'm right speaker I mean how
have been addresses that being confirmed
that we have been Westgate is often that
risk by the sort of the field with areas
of a potential flooding and I think that
was one of the concerns with additional
development being in place from southern
water saying make messages about attend
sure we're drying it issue so if you're
able to just them throughout that one
first place you're not convinced of that
sorry just referring to the the the
proposed or in terms of surface water
drainage it's intended that permit a
paving and soak ways we've been the site
would be provided and KCC raised no
concerns with with this provision in
terms of the foul drainage the intention
is to connect to the existing puppet
failed series in Suffolk Avenue and
solid water arrays no concerted this I
don't think they were I'm not aware
there been any significant drainage
issues that have been raised by the
console T's all of them are satisfied we
have the information that's been
submitted and whilst some of them have
been recommending safeguarding
conditions which is pretty standard the
principle of impacts on drainage they
they have no no significant concerns
with it which is why we you know
recommending approval otherwise we would
have sought to try and address those
issues
thank you are you happy that counts to
Scott my apologies do you have a few on
me so I mean my next question was based
on the concerns knowing the area quite
well Suffolk Avenue and the actual
access into links field I mean at the
moment with relation to our refuse
collections and even our fire department
what is the current accessibility there
we've had issues where we're not where
we had issues of gaining refuse
collections there I means to my
understanding that the current residents
use the the on street parking
whereas most don't have drives and my
concern
following is with the potential of 23
dwellings additional which could bring
in up to 40 plus cars hypothetically
that is going to pose an additional
issue especially with visitors so to go
back to the question have we at this
current moment in time had issues with
our rescued collection or any reports
from fire department can you ever just
share my screen again because there is a
plan that I failed to show you so I
haven't had any comments from the fire
service in terms of this application but
I have spoken to a few concerned
residents about the issues with refuge
and the fact that there are already some
problems within the road for refuge
collection and that you've caused a lots
on both sides and refuge vehicles trying
to come out of the road opposite it can
be quite tight so I'm aware that there
are issues and I think this is what was
picked up by KCC highways and which is
why this issue with the W and an Ives
has been suggested so this plan is
showing the turning in to the site
what for refuge vehicle so it's been
tracks on a 13 meter long vehicle which
is is the standard length vehicle that
we we have within the district for for
refuge collection and it did show that
without the W lines it is gonna be quite
tight to access the site so if cars were
parked where the double yellow lines are
proposed it would be very difficult for
the refuge vehicle to get by and that's
probably why there's current problems
because of the fact there aren't those W
lines that are now so the proposed
always to and when you see these double
these yellow lines on the plan the
proposal is through the legal agreement
for the developer to work with KCC in or
trying and have these w9 put in place
which will help current residents as
well as their proposal so it will allow
for the referee to be able to get into
the road and turn from the road opposite
as well as been out to get into the
actual application site itself for
refugee collections
I hopefully that that will address the
current problem and any any proposed and
future problems right now yeah thank you
I mean the only other thing I mean W
lines we we appreciate them and those
who abide by the the actual law C not to
park on those but we we've had para
synthesis where parking has been RBI
trust enforcement in that area will
obviously continue to ensure that
collections can be maintained with our
waste because I think that's the issue
we we have the the signage we have the
the the lines but it's just the
enforcement and if people who feel
they're they're not getting any
enforcement on it they they start to
continue to think well it hasn't
happened this week it won't happen next
week and so forth so I mean just maybe
something to pay attention so I mean
overall it the actual application itself
is certainly an interesting one I mean
again I'll just to reiterate what counts
the Beaufort's said which was a it is a
shame that where we do actually have a
need for affordable housing that
ironically the offset of a
carbon-neutral house in which to my
understanding was that the whole point
of us to really approach carbon neutral
is to also help build affordable housing
and not have these sort of high-cost
needs so I mean for if a clean and means
a more expensive environment surely
that's a backwards way of doing it but
that's just my own fault I mean really
just to highlight a few things it's just
the concerns that I've felt and
understood and picked up having looked
at the presentation and also the
objections that have been which is the
the concerns of loss of lighting which
has been addressed to some of the the
residents there with the lower levels on
the right side if you're faced in
Norfolk but overall it's still high
density development so potential
development lots of natural lighting and
the the fire
really with the Asus especially with the
actual entrance into the premise
premises themselves the far back
properties I mean if we are able to get
a fire department in there and
excessively I mean we can appreciate and
we can only accept that we've missed a
collection it's frustrating to miss a
life it's you know it's not something
you can complain to the council about
and get it collected the next day I mean
for me is it's a very contentious one I
mean I would always support building on
brownfield sites especially when we are
looking at the local plan and that is
one of the most contentious things is a
very hard one I would like hopefully
other Nimbus is consider these when they
do come up to them below yeah for myself
those were the questions those are the
points I make and I'll certainly leave
it up to the other members thank you
okay Thank You councillor Scott okay
councillor heart thank ya
Matthew quite a bit on this and Jill to
be fair I think it's a good good
thought-out plan
I have great reservations with the fact
that anybody's going to so now say
although there's a double you know I'm
us apart there's no enforcement officers
going to come out at seven o'clock in
the morning give me a ticket just
because a refuse story can't get it I
think it'd be better off not build
houses on that corner so they've got a
better turning area I have used that
little road that goes through believe it
or not quite a few times to delivering
logs because I can't turn and that's
just with a small trailer on the back of
a normal pickup so I do have
reservations about this immensely I
don't I think people are just going to
ignore those double yellows the parking
around there is absolutely hideous and I
don't think although it's a carbon
neutral and well thought out I don't
think they've thought about it enough
and to be honest with you I don't think
I can agree with it just because I just
don't think the access is good enough
for the residents and then it is enough
parking to be fair thank council Huk
councillor Cecily
it's it is an interesting application I
was just a bit concerned the fact that
we couldn't have any low-cost housing
with it I am intrigued by the point that
it's going to cost more for these houses
yet they're not going to make a
contribution that upsets me
it does this mean that anyone who does a
zero carbon development can expect to
I'd not pay any contributions in the
future Emma can you or would you rather
leave that I mean this was an issue that
we we were concerned about when
assessing the application because we we
we didn't want to be accepting a carb or
zero scheme on the basis that we were
then not getting affordable housing
because so we we did ask when we've had
the independent review carried out on
the viability we've asked them to look
at two things with awesome to look at
the viability based on this scheme so we
resolved zero carbon scheme what what is
the viability is it is it cheaper to
achieve any affordable housing or
contributions and because the build
costs were much higher per unit whilst
the values of the properties would be
higher it still showed that the scheme
is a Bible and I believe that's probably
because it's a previous developer site
you've got your 16 buildings on it you
can have the cost of demolition that's
going to be a problem as well so that's
all added to it and and and resulted in
it not being a viable scheme but we also
asked for out in terms of the
independent review for them to consider
if it was built without the zero carbon
features and was a standard field would
we then achieve contributions or
affordable housing and in that case it
was also found it was still on viable so
in either case it's on viable so the
zero carbon is an added benefit to the
environment but in either case we would
just not be able to secure any
affordable housing there's there would
have been maybe some scope through a
standard build scheme to maybe have got
a very very small financial contribution
potentially
but we felt that the benefits of the
zero-carbon probably outweighed the
potential you have pushing them to go
for a status scheme in order to achieve
those tiny for those small benefits and
for that reason we've actually suggested
a condition that says that they have to
build it to this zero carbon standard
and it's only on that on that round that
we've accepted no contributions but as I
said in either case we've knocked out a
secure affordable housing on Hicks it's
just knocks it to be a sustainable site
for that so yes it will be the loss of
seven affordable units on the site and
it is unfortunate but it's just it's
just not viable in any case so so yeah
and in terms of the highway point if I
could just come back on that as well so
highways KCC have not raised any
objections to it so whilst it's only one
parking space per unit they are only all
one or two bed units there's no large
units on the site in addition to that
they're proposing seven visitor parking
spaces and highways are happy that this
does meet our minimum standards for
parking provision in the area and
therefore have raised no concern so I
appreciate that there may be a lack of
parking provision in the area although
saying that there's quite a few
semi-detached properties that do have
off street parking and when I visit the
site during the day there does appear to
be spare capacity in the area although I
appreciate in the evenings it might be
might be worse than that but on the
basis of the fact that we can achieve
one one part of space per unit passes
plus the seven visitor parking spaces
that there's no highway objection to the
part of the vision okay thank you and
I'm gonna bring in mr. Livingstone just
a comment please Thank You chair don't
go over the ground that that Emma's
clearly explained the Dodds to the
affordable housing and the viability of
the site but I think just did just give
him some comfort that you know as you've
heard we did look at this in quite a lot
of detail and including modeling a lot
of different scenarios about different
prices that might be yet be be found for
these type of products and only one of
those I think seven scenarios did there
come out as a short surplus which
obviously then led to the decision about
the the condition and just a touch of
the highways point as well and in terms
of the
enforcement issue about yellow lines
obviously this is something that members
are familiar with with other schemes
where housing developments would have
you know yellow lines linked either in
the legal obligation through best
endeavors to be sought from the
applicants to go to KCC for a traffic
regulation order but I think I just want
to make it clear to members that
concerns about traffic enforcement not
doing their job it is not a valid issue
to look at in terms of Highway Safety if
if it happen if we get the yellow lines
through this application which is up see
what we're looking to secure then people
not adhering to traffic regulations is
not something that we could take into
account in a planning decision and it's
something that would certainly be I'm
sure flagged up by residents and then
for flagged up by the other enforcement
team in the council so I just want to
give members one the assurance that that
would be looked out but also to make
sure that isn't any way affecting the
decision that members are making thank
you chair Thank You Anne councillor
garner thank you thank you very much
yeah well firstly it does sound like an
excellent carbon-neutral housing
development that's going to be on the on
the site
I do have serious reservations though
about there not being any affordable
housing and how all any contribution
though I accept I listen to and accept
the explanation you gave I think my
concern going forward would be that any
new developments that a carbon-neutral
as they should be will use this or or or
their carbon neutrality as an excuse to
get to get out of providing affordable
housing and to making their
contributions because obviously we're
very really are short of affordable
units so if maybe see if maybe mr.
lammeter could come back and give me
some assurance the future
developments on brownfield sites won't
be coming back to us saying we can only
do carbon neutral if we don't provide
affordable housing Thank You Ian Thank
You chair so this is an issue that was
actually discussed quite a bit of length
at the local plant examination when
considering whole planned viability
specifically when looking at previous
land sites and it is the case that with
brownfield sites with buildings
currently on it that it simply costs
more to redevelop those sites and by
virtue of SM are referred to earlier
demolition costs are quite significant
and they are abnormal costs and then all
of the work that has to go into actually
constructing around the rest of the
built form in the area so those sites
are going to be potentially hit by
viability concerns that only does amount
to a a smaller proportion of the
allocated sites in the in a local plan
as well as that in this part of Westgate
you know we are not looking at the
significant or higher value areas of the
district so that again puts a bit of a
burden in terms of the GDP that you'd be
getting back in terms of these
particular this particular scheme so you
know it's it's a consideration that we
have to look at on every single
application for development on PDL but
every single site is different and I
think in this instance this is a very
unique scheme that they're proposing not
only because the abnormal cost that they
have to deal with because it's been an
industrial site for a number of years um
but there are other sites that are going
to come forward where we're going to
have to look at this it's certainly not
a precedent that's being set though
because of every site in every part of
the district that comes forward like
this is going to have their own very
specific costs that we will be analyzing
in every single instance I think one
point I just want to raise as well
is that when considering the I suppose
the lack of affordable housing so it's
not the loss of affordable housing the
lack of affordable housing of the scheme
and that there are obviously other
benefits from this point forward as emma
has already elaborated upon the
than its allocated site for housing but
also the fact that you're removing a use
which is incompatible with those
residential uses around at the moment
and that has led environmental health
complaints so there there are benefits
that outweigh the fact that there aren't
providing the affordable housing which
as a lab rated by Emma could not be not
be provided even if this wasn't a carbon
neutral zero carbon scheme thank you
thank you and I know two counts as Scott
has made a note he has come back but I
think possibly counts to Scott or
questions may well have been answered it
was just really on the just the carbon
side I mean obviously if the particular
development for that area they are
looking to personally the zero carbon I
mean I trust that they put in position
for the parking spaces for that
particular defendant at least the the
charging points I mean if we're
encouraging to have zero carbon housing
next obviously obvious method is to
encourage carbon zero transport so I
mean is that something that could be
considered in development or will be
considered into the development for the
area charging points I think that has
been done correct me if I'm wrong Liana
I think that has been done ever so
usually in the form of one space per
allocated also I just found the
condition condition 22 so price the
first occupation of the development
electric vehicle charging points ought
to be provided in the form of one active
space per 10 unallocated spaces and one
active space per allocated space so
where it's a property where the space
within their current fish they have to
always provided actually being charged
in or
if it's a communal parking area where
you've got the seven visitor parking
spaces then where every every ten of
those one of those should be a charging
point and that is now become a pretty
standard for almost development we're
doing we're requiring that vision okay
what I do is for missing that thank you
no thank you I thought I spotted it I
can't see you anymore because so I'm
going now to put this to you then that
he's recommend as say the officers
recommendation which is for approval
again your names out for four against or
to abstain counselor calm cook for
Council at your papers for council Alan
curry for cancer John Dennis for thank
you John counselor might garner or
counsel David Hart for counselor Heather
keen for counselor Pat Moore for cancer
Georgia Rose esky abstain counsel
Matthew Scott against accountant in the
right four I'm for it as well sounds
like that has been carried I'll make
sure it comes up on there Thank You ver
MIDI as always I believe that concludes
the meeting this afternoon yes I believe
so
Thank You members and officers our next
meeting is two weeks time
when's the same time I know fully
appreciate that for some members it is
difficult to come it along but you know
I appreciate your time so I will call
which is reaching to an end and so